il museo di merda praticamente tu Entri
e ci sono queste merde colorate
Ciao ragazzi che bello che ci ritroviamo
ogni tanto eh che faccio youtuber non so
bene che titolo avrà questo vlog ma c'è
un viaggio fantastico che abbiamo in
canna Dove mi trovo in questo momento
Giampiero fai l'effetto con Google Maps
e questo No scherzo Non lo fare
in questo momento Ragazzi mi trovo a
Trapani e sono qua per il Trapani Comics
Questo è il retro Oggi è il 19 maggio
questa è una piccola tappa del viaggio
che sto per fare perché oggi in segreto
ho organizzato una cosa incredibile
venite con me in questo viaggio
incredibile Perché se avete seguito gli
episodi in Giappone i prossimi video che
usciranno da questo in avanti saranno
altrettanto incredibile e lo vedrete
molto presto compreso questo video Let's
go Siccome siamo qua a quest'intervista
al Trapani
siamo a Trapani Comics io sto parlando
al microfono a Voi che guardate i video
non vi serve il microfono ma serve a
loro sono non mi sentono e questa è la
prima tappa del vlog salutate ragazzi ah
Ecco col mio amo il mio lavoro e Siete
bellissimi belli metterò questo pezzo
nel blog Siete contenti
fantastico Bonjour Allora ragazzi Come
posso spiegarvi questa cosa sto per
partire sono nella Lounge dita Airways
Preparatevi perché compreso questo video
e i prossimi tre o quattro ci sarà un
altro viaggio completamente a sorpresa
non ho annunciato niente Non vi posso
dire perché lo sto facendo ma lo
scoprirete
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Vabbè già business sarete chiedendo ma
che ci fa Favij in una business Class
faccio SurrealPower Allora ragazzi e
bella spaziosa abbiamo la carta dei vini
che a me non serve a un emerito Cattivo
Mi hanno portato ho già fatto una figura
di cacca perché è arrivata la hostess
con tipo sei drink e io pensavo mi
dispiace tanto tutti invece Dovevo
scegliere e ho scelto questo che sembra
alcolico Quindi ho fatto anche la scelta
sbagliata alla vostra dopodiché abbiamo
il sedile che diventa letto quindi si
può Adesso non lo faccio perché in fase
di decollo non si può fare ma dopo mi
stenderò è un mega schermo non stimare
alcun oggetto sopra o sotto il
poggiapiedi
Dopodiché mi avvantaggio di questo
splendido di questo splendido un cazzo
si fa Deve essere un tasso no no no no
[Applauso]
mamma mia Proprio lui dice ci
avantaggiamo di questa affare per farvi
vedere che cosa ci danno in omaggio una
volta in business abbiamo questa magica
sono calze magiche calze va bene profumo
Ferragamo tutto Ferragamo a quanto pare
Ah questo è per dormire a questa sì che
mi serve a me
l'attrezzo giusto e poi abbiamo tre
quello che credo sia un dentifricio
portatile Eccolo qua fantastico e poi
abbiamo Ovviamente questa che ci
lasciano poi l'astuccio che È gigantesco
e infine Ragazzi ho notato L'ho notato
solo adesso questo magico vano che si
apre e all'interno c'è un mini tablet
che noi possiamo staccare ed utilizzare
che ci c'è umidità vedete più un iPhone
Praticamente ci permette di controllare
questo a distanza franzettino tattico
con pane salmone e palle di ferro
[Musica]
E questa Oggi abbiamo il driver
Ciao ragazzi siamo a Foggia dopo un mese
passato
a Milano per vacanze e poi sono andato a
Tokyo venite torna in Italia per fare le
vacanze il contrario siamo in Giappone
ma adesso vi dico perché non è una cosa
normale Adesso vi spiego faremo delle
grandi cose perché non sono qua per
vacanze perché non sono pazzo che sono
tornato dopo un mese sono qua per fare
delle grandi cose che non vi posso dire
ma adesso arriviamo in albergo che vi
spiego Perfetto Adesso sì che siamo a
casa
[Musica]
sto capendo niente allora mi stanno
portando nell'albergo E comunque
a farci due u cazz Ragazzi ma in che
posto pazzesco sono in che posto
pazzesco un suono Non sono mai stato in
un albergo così figo in Giappone Raga ma
sono curiosissimo della mia stanza a
questo punto e questa raga è la stanza
47 2 1 Madonna che figo Oh che posto
Pazzesco Tra l'altro mi hanno già dato
226 drink va bene quindi io sono a posto
Vediamo la stanza raga No ma sono Questa
volta sono incredibilmente curioso
perché non l'ho vista vediamo
[Musica]
Ciao l'ho vista le foto intendo
Ok ok va bene
una stanzina proprio Vediamola
[Musica]
non esistono in Giappone abbastanza così
È incredibile non ha senso Sono
scioccato
Allora questo sono io post 14 ore di
aereo
Hai il cesso perché il cesso giustamente
non è nel bagno ma in un coso a parte ok
E poi c'è anche una scatola di benvenuto
attenzione No vabbè ragazzi incredibile
[Musica]
no
sono dei cavi dei cavi Ethernet grazie
grazie
No veramente
Questo è il davanzale del balcone non so
come sia possibile che è più grosso
della stanza Che minchia succede sono a
Tokyo per un progetto del quale non vi
posso dire niente ma farò dei video per
questa cosa i prossimi giorni nei
prossimi due o tre giorni sono stato
chiamato qua apposta per questo e ho
detto assolutamente sì questi video li
vedrete circa a metà giugno poi vi dirò
precisamente quando e siccome sono
tornato a Tokyo ho detto Vabbè già che
torno Non è che sto qua 3 giorni e me ne
torno a Milano ho detto no però lungo la
mia vacanza e me ne sto per i fatti miei
E quindi so di nuovo tre settimane
siccome avevo appena portato 5 vlog
appunto qua in Giappone ho detto è un
peccato rimanere solo qua quindi i
prossimi due video saranno
in Corea ho deciso di andare finalmente
a Seul vado in Corea del Sud perché c'è
un è circa a un paio d'ore di aereo da
qua soli 5 o 6 giorni e vi porterò due
video di Seul perché non ci sono mai
stati incoraggi Non ho idea di come sia
Sinceramente non mi voglio spoilerare
niente quindi ragazzi Per farla breve
Adesso avete questo video che appunto un
video in Giappone i prossimi due video
saranno due video a Seul e poi tornerò
l'ultima settimana sempre qua a Tokyo
Farò un altro video appunto di Tokyo e
poi me ne torno a Milano per mettere la
testa sui due video che sto per
registrare nel frattempo
Godiamoci del buon sushi i terrakimas
buono No ragazzi ma questa questo è il
giardino dell'albergo ma sto male raga
c'è incredibile ma che albergo è Ma dove
sono finito
[Musica]
Che emozione Adesso farò il parroco In
Giappone è curioso come ogni posto che
visito in Giappone sia unico nel suo
genere e merita solo quello un blog io
mi devo fermare nel fare contenuti
perché sennò non mi godrei niente perché
ogni metro c'è qualcosa da da fare da
filmare robe e son venuto tante volte
ragazzi hanno le 7:30 del mattino non ho
dormito moltissimo perché vabbè primo
giorno jet lag come sempre ma se io Ora
le ho fatte quindi neanche troppo male
Mi sono alzato presto sono venuto qua
shibuya perché fare colazione qui in
questo punto in questo Starbucks che da
sullo shibuyaspo e non è mai facile
perché è sempre pieno e mi sto godendo
un paio di cookies se questo magico
Magic cappuccino e siamo quindi tornati
a dodaiba un'altra volta Ma ragazzi non
avevo notato una cosa Scusate negli
ultimi vlog Meno male che sono tornati
in Giappone perché c'è di fianco l'unico
musium che è niente popò di meno e popò
di meno non lo dico a caso il museo
della nerd il museo di merda
praticamente tu Entri e ci sono queste
merde colorate e vendono la merda Cioè
proprio anche la merda dentro la
Pocket merda è fighissimo ragazzi
una merda costa 1.600 yen
Ragazzi stiamo per mangiare nel ramen
numero uno del mondo perché numero uno
del Giappone vengono nel mondo insieme
agli Sharan ed è shibuya ci vengo quasi
tutti gli anni e c'è scritto che non si
possono fare graffiti non si può rubare
non si può registrare niente quindi già
una regola è andata a non si
possono dire parolacce non si può recare
danni agli oggetti alle cose e non si
può puzzare le regole magiche
probabilmente in Italia questo cartello
non c'è vi spiego come funziona raga
avete tutta la roba da prendere se
stessi selezionare quello che si vuole
mangiare dovrebbe comparire Ah comparsa
scusa e poi uno mette i soldi
direttamente nel coso di soldi
Bisognerebbe cacare i soldi ovviamente e
il bigliettino che te dai al tizio che
poi ti fa ramen Adesso vi faccio vedere
abbiamo anche una schermata che ci
indica quali posti sono liberi quindi
sono verdi e gli altri Rossi sono
occupati e noi andremo a sederci al
tavolo e metteremo i biglietti Eccoci
qua Ragazzi allora poi mettiamo i nostri
bigliettini uno e della degli extra del
pezzettino extra di carne è uno dei è
uno del Ramen li mettiamo qua Questo è
un foglio che ho compilato per far
vedere come lo voglio condito mettiamo
qua e qua di fianco ci sono questi
piccoli pezzetti di legno che se tu vuoi
comunicare qualcosa lo lo Poggi qua e ti
pare ad esempio questo è non so come
funzionano gli ordini quelli che avevo
spiegato prima perché magari sono
persone che non sanno come si fa Oppure
me ne sto andando per un attimo e adesso
passerà un tizio a fregarmi tutti i
fogli tutti anche mezzi bagnati dalla
pioggia va bene chiude la tendina perché
questa è una tendina che si chiude non
lo faccio io perché credono
Ragazzi grazie Giovanna
posizionato solamente nella vasca Grazie
Giovanna Ecco qua perfetto la privacy ce
l'abbiamo si capisce che tipo di privacy
perché tanto non si vede comunque un
cazzo Volendo possiamo intanto bere con
questo spinner
Yes
mangia bene Mi piace che sarà sarà
settecentesimo video che faccio a Tokyo
e comunque c'è sempre roba da registrare
non ti annoi mai Grazie Jones Grazie
Giovanni Grazie
fichissimo
addirittura Ma grazie a te grazie a te
ma grazie a te ma non c'è bisogno
ammazza Bono ragazzi piccolo piccolo
che il negozio di elettronica più famoso
di tutto il Giappone e alla fine è il
più grande quindi questo ci permette di
girare a cazzo anche nei momenti di noia
non che ci sia da annoiarsi a Tokyo Eh
però Vabbè ragazzi in questo vlog
Comunque ho fatto un po'
fantastico giro di Tokyo eccetera però
sto cercando di farvi vedere cose che
magari non vi avevo fatto vedere negli
altri vlog nel mentre che aspettiamo il
biagione a Seul che non vedo l'ora
Ragazzi ma comunque
ci accontentiamo Ecco Ditemi voi se mi
trova accontentare di stare a Tokyo in
bocca Vabbè e siccome ragazzi devo
lasciare la stanza d'albergo domani
perché ehm devo cambiare albergo Ma poi
vedrete dove sto andando Ho fatto lavare
la roba sporca perché c'è il servizio
lavanderia e mi hanno riportato tutto
con il foglio Lorenzo o Strunz perfetto
Sono proprio io e per spostarci
l'albergo ragazzi utilizziamo un
famosissimo mezzo di locomazione
giapponese il treno di Hello Kitty
adesso ne passerà il prossimo che sarà
il nostro quindi ragazzi Quale migliore
location per chiudere questo video se
non tutta Tokyo in questo momento non è
che sono tipo isolato chiodavo era una
cosa del genere ma nella mia stanza
d'albergo semplicemente ve la faccio
vedere nel prossimo video perché sennò
facciamo tutti in questo E vabbè Mi sono
appena svegliato Scusate le occhiaie
però almeno mi è passato il jet lag con
oggi si parte e ci vediamo al prossimo
video ragazzi perché andremo appunto
come vi avevo detto in Corea infatti ci
sto poco in questa stanza qua ci sto un
paio di giorni e poi Let's go ragazzi
iscrivetevi al canale lasciate un bel mi
piace come ultima cosa volevo dirvi che
sono uscite le magliette Qua c'è scritto
Favij tutti in giapponese Appunto perché
sono magliette per l'evento del viaggio
Dateci un'occhiata perché le trovate in
descrizione sono molto carine e